die erste Frage an Sie Herr Roth ab wann
seit wann wussten sie Bescheid dass
Leoparden geliefert werden die Ukraine
das zeichnete sich ja schon ab in den
vergangenen Tagen und Wochen wann
wussten sie es jetzt heute
ich spüre das also sie wussten es nicht
ich spüre das das nicht ich spüre das
dass das wie kann man sie außen vor
lassen als Chef des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses
wir haben gestern beispielsweise im
Präsidium der SPD darüber geredet wir
haben am Freitag darüber geredet auch in
Anwesenheit das Bundeskanzlers ist eine
Regierungsentscheidung ich habe mich
öffentlich dazu geäußert und morgen
haben wir Bundestagssitzung und ich bin
mir sicher der wird auch der
Bundeskanzler etwas dazu sagen in
Anwesenheit der Abgeordneten aller
Fraktion am Freitag noch mit ihm
zusammen nee am gestern saßen sie noch
mit ihm zusammen und er hat nichts
gesagt wir haben darüber geredet über
diese Frage auch darüber
aber hat nicht gesagt wir machen es wir
haben uns da noch an einem
Diskussionsprozess Befunden sie haben es
da auch noch nicht geahnt oder gerochen
die Sie gerade sagen also ich habe es
eigentlich gespürt also einfach nichts
ich wusste nicht wann aber ich hatte es
gespürt und ich habe es natürlich auch
gehofft zum einen weil die Ukraine diese
Panzer dringend braucht zum anderen weil
ich den Eindruck habe das ist inzwischen
eine große Zahl von europäischen Staaten
gibt er bereit sind in einem Team diese
Kampfpanzer zur Verfügung zu stellen und
ich im übrigen der Auffassung bin das
ist jetzt auch in der Zeit ist gegenüber
den Partnern in Europa aber auch
gegenüber den USA deutlich zu machen die
haben schon viel geleistet und diesen
Schritt gehen wir jetzt auch der will
noch mal fragen wer sagt da gestern
genau zusammen sie der Kanzler wer war
das sind die gewählten Mitglieder des
SPD-Präsidium wir treffen uns 14 täglich
und der Bundeskanzler lässt sich nicht
nehmen an diesen Sitzungen auch
teilzunehmen zuzuhören
aber eben auch mit uns zu diskutieren
und keine 24 Stunden später entscheidet
der offenbar etwas von dem er keinem was
gesagt hat er wird natürlich mit dem
Partner darüber geredet haben
die Tatsache dass er so lange gezögert
hat hatte ja vor allen Dingen mit der
SPD zu tun nur den Eindruck hatte ich
nicht ich habe eher den Eindruck gehabt
den Eindruck hatte ich nicht sondern ich
hatte er den Eindruck dass es
offenkundig bei einigen Partnern auch
noch einen gewissen Abstimmungsbedarf
gibt sind ja auch deutliche Signale
gesendet worden nicht nur von Polen
sondern auch aus anderen Ländern und wir
haben immer gesagt wir wollen eine
europäische Lösung wir wollen die
internationale Lösung ich habe den
Vorschlag der schon im September
unterbreitet dass wir eine europäische
Allianz Staaten für den Leo hat die Zeit
war damals noch nicht reif jetzt ist sie
reif und jetzt kriegen wir das auch hin
wenn man da so zusammensetzt ne ich will
jetzt
gerne mal verstehen wie diese Art von
Kommunikation läuft
was war der Stand also wir haben Sie
darüber ger damit könnte man müsste man
sollte man eher nicht eher ja hast du
gehört was andere Annemarie
strak Zimmermann erzählt hat im ZDF und
so weiter also erst einmal ist meine
Partei auch ein Spiegel unserer
Gesellschaft das heißt da gibt es
Menschen die sind ungeduldig so wie ich
und die treiben eher an und die wollen
eher Mut machen es gibt etwas behutsamer
und zurückhaltender und das hat sich
auch in den Diskussionen wieder
gespiegelt aber es ist üblich dass man
aus solchen Sitzungen auch öffentlich
nichts erzählt das heißt sie haben ihn
versucht zu überzeugen und er trifft
dann aber am Ende der einsame
Entscheidung nein er trifft als
Bundeskanzler diese Entscheidungen ja
nicht als Mitglied des Präsidiums ist
klar ich habe jedenfalls großen Respekt
davor ich wüsste nicht wie ich in einer
solchen Situation zu entscheiden habe
weil ich kann beraten ich kann das
öffentlich vorschlagen ich kann das auch
fordern aber am Ende direkt er die
Verantwortung dazu er muss das auch mit
seinem Gewissen vereinbaren und das ist
nicht ganz einfach deswegen tue ich mich
auch immer schwer das jetzt
personalisieren die einen sind gut die
anderen sind schlecht am Ende wird die
Geschichte zeigen ob ich recht gehabt
habe oder andere aber sie wissen ja
selber Rechthaber mag man nicht weder in
der Schule noch in der Politik deswegen
haben sie es da auch manchmal schwer ich
frage deswegen so genau nach weil ich
mich erinnert dass Frau Hermann an an
die Vorgänge rund um die Berufung des
neuen Verteidigungsministers ich meine
da der wird Robert Habeck der jetzt
nicht irgendjemand ist sondern
Vizekanzler in Davos gefragt werden neue
Verteidigungsminister oder Ministerin
wird und er sagt ich gehe davon aus es
wird eine Frau
er war so offenkundig nicht informiert
der Vizekanzler und dann irgendwann auf
einer kurzen Autofahrt so habe ich es
jetzt gehört rund um den Frankfurter
Flughafen glaube ich ruft der Kanzler
aus dem Auto den Vizekanzler an und sagt
ihm das und 30 Minuten später weiß es
auch die gesamte Presse was ist das für
eine Art miteinander umzugehen also ich
muss jetzt sagen das ist aus meiner
Sicht jetzt nicht ein Skandal weil es ja
so ist
das von Vertrauen innerhalb einer
Regierungskoalition das ist kein Skandal
aber das wirkt alles immer sehr einsam
sehr man man spricht sich nicht hat man
redet eigentlich gar nicht ähm ja also
was man ja festhalten muss ist in diesem
Fall durfte die SPD entscheiden und zwar
der Kanzler war jetzt da der
Verteidigungsminister wird das war jetzt
nicht etwas was die Grünen entscheiden
dürfen
nicht jemand der jetzt große Kreise in
eine
Entscheidung einbezieht sondern es ist
so dass er alles im Wesentlichen mit
seinem Kanzleramtschef Wolfgang Schmidt
bespricht und dieser kleine Kreis
entscheidet dann jetzt muss ich aber
sagen dass wenn es um sowas geht wie
Leoparden oder so bündnisentscheidungen
finde ich das nicht schlimm weil am Ende
ist es ja der Kanzler der die
Verhandlung führt er ist auch derjenige
der am Ende die Entscheidung fällt und
das jetzt nicht alle immer eingeweiht
sind wenn man diplomatisch sehr
schwierige Prozesse steuern muss kann
ich verstehen also
sozusagen nicht mal
wenn man nicht mal gewillt ist ganz
offenkundig die eigene Leute mitzunehmen
Herr rot ist ja jetzt nicht irgendwer
ist jemand der sich zu diesem Thema viel
geäußert hat viele Gedanken macht ein
profilierter spd-außenpolitiker der zu
einem sehr frühen Zeitpunkt auch schon
in die Ukraine gefahren ist der die
Situation dort kennt ja im September
bereits gesagt hat ich glaube wir
sollten diesen Leoparden jetzt liefern
selbst der sitzt jetzt hier und ist
völlig kalt erwischt von dieser
Nachricht so wie es Robert habe ich
neulich in Davos auch war der davon
ausgehen dass eine Frau
Verteidigungsministerin wird wie soll
man dann wenn man die eigene
Regierungskoalition die eigene Partei
ganz offenkundig nicht mitnehmen kann
ein ganzes Land mitnehmen
also den ersten Tag kann ich ihn nicht
beantworten das ist sozusagen die
Geflogenheiten die die Regierung unter
sich einübt das ist sozusagen der deren
Teil was ja im Kabinettstisch machen ich
finde es den letzten Teil finde ich
bemerkenswert weil es ja doch zum
Grundprinzip von Demokratie gehört dass
man das was man tut begründet
und man wir sind jetzt alle auf der
einen Seite erstmal sehr glücklich wenn
die Nachrichten nicht stimmen dass die
Ukraine die Waffensysteme bekommt das
ist glaube ich erstmal das wichtigste
was man hier unterstreichen muss und
danach kommt was wie wir in Deutschland
zu der Entscheidung gekommen sind und
ich hätte mir gewünscht weil es ja doch
eine Frage von großer öffentlicher
Bedeutung ist
das genau diese Fragen tatsächlich dann
auch öffentlich erklärt worden wären
ohne dass deswegen Entscheidung
vorweggenommen wäre aber ich glaube
gerade wenn man die Kaffeesatzleserei
rund um Randstein gesehen hat was der
Kanzler denkt und was nicht also die
ganzen Psychologisierung sind glaube ich
einfach sehr sehr schwierig gewesen und
haben sowohl
innenpolitisch in der in der Wirkung der
Kommunikation nicht wunderbar nach uns
nach vorne gebracht aber auch mit Blick
auf unsere Partner nicht also mit
anderen Worten da ist wir haben keinen
kein gutes Ansehen gerade da draußen
nein genau also jetzt kann man natürlich
es ist jetzt kann man natürlich sagen
wunderbar der Kanzler hat es geschafft
offensichtlich nach den Meldungen die
wir jetzt haben die sind ja noch nicht
von der ersten Quelle bestätigt worden
die USA auf seine Seite zu zwingen ähm
das Problem ist immer es gibt nach einem
Spiel das nächste Spiel und in dieses
Spiel geht man mit den Ergebnissen des
letzten Spiel zwar noch mit den
Erinnerungen daran mich so gelaufen ist
und ähm das ist in der in der Diplomatie
oder in der Politik etwas gerade da wo
es Umhausen Politik geht wo man wo man
sich aufeinander verlassen muss weil
sonst keine Regeln gibt und die Frage
wenn ich dir die Hand gebe passt das
dann oder worauf können wir uns
verständigen dann ist es sehr schwierig
daher kommt auch die These dass das hier
wahrscheinlich doch ein Flurschaden
verursacht hat für die Zukunft
Deutschland ist deswegen nicht komplett
isoliert unsere Partnerin nicht weg aber
sie werden ab sofort ein Risikoaufschlag
zahlen müssen für die Politik wenn Sie
die versuchen wollen mit Partnern
durchzubringen weil die sagen naja wenn
ich mir in existenziellen Fragen auf
Deutschland verlasse muss ich dann noch
mal den gleichen Eiertanz mitmachen wie
wir es in der leopardfrage gehabt haben
Frau Hermann ja also ich muss zugeben
ich sehe das ja ganz anders also nee
das ist gut weil sie tendenziell die
Dinge immer ganz anders sehen
gut also ich meine etwas Scholz
erreichen wollte ist dass wenn
Deutschland Leoparden liefert die
Amerikaner ebenfalls Kampfpanzer liefern
was soll's nicht haben wollte ist ein
deutschen Alleingang nur deutsche
liefern Leoparden oder geben die
Erlaubnis an andere Länder die in
Deutschland produzierten Lippen
Leoparden in die Ukraine zu exportieren
bedeutet stolz wollte unbedingt dass
auch andere Kampfpanzer anderer Bauart
aus dem Westen in die Ukraine gehen
damit es ein gemeinsamer
Vorstoß ist und jetzt muss man mal sagen
nachdem was man jetzt hört hat verscholz
wahrscheinlich genau dieses Ziel
erreicht in dem die Amerikaner jetzt
ihren Abrams Kampfpanzer ebenfalls
liefern und das ist wenn das stimmt
wissen wir ja nicht genau ein
sensationeller diplomatischer Erfolg und
den kann man nicht erfinden ja das finde
ich wirklich und das kann man nicht
erzwingen indem man vorher mit allen
redet also nichts gegen Herrn rot aber
man hat ja gesehen was passiert ist
einmal hat nämlich stolz versucht
demokratischen Abgeordneten aus den USA
zu erklären was er will er hat ihm
gesagt ich will ich liefere Leoparden
wenn die USA Abrams Kampfpanzer liefert
und dann gab es sofort weil er es
öffentlich gemacht hat gegenüber diesen
Abgeordneten aus dem präsentantenhaus
gab es so sofort eine schwere
diplomatische Verstimmung mit dem
Verteidigungsminister der USA und mit
dem US-Präsidenten Joe Biden weil das
möchte natürlich die USA überhaupt nicht
erleben das so aussieht als würde ein
Kanzler aus Deutschland die USA
erpressen und dann deswegen weil dann
immer alle Gefühle ja von diesen ganzen
staatslenkern involviert sind muss man
diese Gespräche hinter den Kulissen
führen und man muss sie in kleinem Kreis
führen und wenn das so ist in letzter
Satz das ist Joyce geschafft hat jetzt
Abrahams Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine zu
lenken dann ist das sensationell dann
hat er nämlich den Kuh ein zweites Mal
wiederholt es war ja so alle haben immer
gesagt ja Deutschland muss
Schützenpanzer Marder liefern Scholz
immer nein ich keine Mader so lange
nicht die anderen liefern was war das
Ergebnis die USA schicken jetzt 59 oder
50 man weiß es nicht genau Bradleys und
ähm die Franzosen schicken jetzt auch
Spürpanzer und das Ergebnis von dieser
ganzen Scholz diplomatie ist das muss
man jetzt mal ganz deutlich sagen dass
am Ende in der Ukraine sehr viel mehr
Waffen sind als der je gewesen wäre wenn
Deutschland sofort immer liefern würde
ja das ist doch sensationell und ja ja
große die große Strategie dahinter
also ihren Wunsch nach Transparenz in
allen Ehren aber ich war mit der
vergangenen Woche mit diesem Wochenende
alles andere als glücklich erstens hat
uns der Streit in der Koalition
überhaupt nicht gut getan so die Leute
haben Angst den die die machen sich
Sorgen und dann streiten wir uns wie die
Kesselflicker und ich halte es auch
nicht für hilfreich wenn alliierte die
bislang ganz ganz viel getan haben dass
die Ukraine sich befreien kann von
diesem russischen Accessor wenn wir
öffentlich darüber streiten wer liefert
was ich glaube da muss man auch ein
Grund Vertrauen haben in diejenigen die
das zu verantworten haben die das zu
verhandeln haben und das ist jetzt
offenkundig ein gutes Ergebnis gibt das
ist das Verdienst von ganz vielen ich
hätte jedenfalls vor einer Woche nicht
damit gerechnet dass die US-Amerikaner
offenkundig auch bereit sind diese
Abrams zu liefern wo er immer gesagt
wurde die sind technisch problematisch
die kann man schwieriger einsetzen als
zum Beispiel Leopards von denen wir ja
in Europa 2000 haben in 13 europäischen
Staaten das heißt ihre Begeisterung für
den eigenen Kanzler hält sich in
deutlich engeren Grenzen als die von
Frau Hermann doch das gleiche gesagt für
ihn
wo haben Sie jetzt den Unterschied
daraus gehört na ja also sie sagen sie
haben sich öffentlich gestritten wie die
Kesselflicker und das ist ja richtig und
das hat mich genervt richtig finde das
nicht gut weil ich finde in einer
Koalition geht man anders miteinander um
bei aller Wertschätzung für meine
Kollegin Marie agnesstag Zimmermann aber
ich finde so etwas macht man öffentlich
nicht das kann man hinter verschlossenen
Türen machen und da finde ich ja auch
deutlich geworden und genauso ist es
glaube ich nicht hilfreich wenn man sich
als alliierte und als Verbündete der
Ukraine öffentlich unter Druck setzt da
muss ich sagen Respekt vor den
US-Amerikanern Respekt gegenüber seinen
beiden ähm da hat es nie kritische Worte
auch uns gegenüber gegeben und am Ende
stimmen ja die Ergebnisse auch wenn ich
mir manches früher gewünscht hätte wir
sind neben dem Vereinten Königreich und
weit natürlich nach den USA auf Platz 2
weil der militärischen Unterstützung der
Ukraine und jetzt kommt noch mehr es tut
mir es fällt mir schwer dazu sagen ich
freue mich aber ich habe den Eindruck
das hilft der Ukraine in ihrem
Freihandel sie wollten das schon in den
Vorschlag habe ich gemacht aber da
musste ich auch einsehen die Zeit war
offensichtlich noch nicht reif hat sich
ja niemand so richtig dazu verhalten
herrling wollte gerade aber weil sie
gerade Marianne stark Zimmermann erwähnt
haben vielleicht zeigen aber auch unter
vier Augen gesagt nicht dass sie jetzt
den Eindruck haben ich sag das jetzt
noch
öffentlich gesagt und damit und auch
hier in ähnlichen Worten auch vielleicht
hören wir einmal kurz rein damit wir
alle wissen worum es geht und was da
wirklich öffentlich gesagt wurde bitte
schön
ist historisch da muss der hat der
amerikanische Verteidigungsminister
Recht die Geschichte schaut auf uns und
Deutschland hat leider gerade versagt
auf der anderen Seite ist diese
Kommunikation eine Katastrophe und das
kann man auch keine mehr erklären denn
wenn der Kanzler das nicht will dann
muss er das erklären er muss es uns
erklären er muss es vor allen Dingen den
Menschen draußen erklären und vor allen
Dingen Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainern heute
Abend kann sich Wladimir Putin auf die
Schenkel klopfen der übrigens gerade
Massenmörder frei lässt damit sie an der
Front kämpfen das ist so ein
bestialischer Krieg da kann man nur die
Ukraine unterstützen und wenn man es
nicht macht weil man die der Ukraine
helfen will dann weil man ein Land ein
Bündnis verteidigen will und
offensichtlich hat einfach ich bleibe
mal im Bilde diesen Knall er ist im
Kanzleramt noch nicht angekommen und ich
finde es wirklich unangenehm ich finde
es auch wirklich zutiefst betrüblich und
es war harmlos auszudrücken
dass meine Ansage was haben sie ja
gesagt unter vier Augen das werde ich
Ihnen nicht sagen aber ich gehöre ja
auch zum Fanclub deutlicher Aussprache
aber so etwas macht man unter Partnerin
und Partnern nicht und ich finde auch
diese Personalisierung nicht in Ordnung
wir haben einen sachlichen Streit
niemand von uns der hier sitzt kann für
sich in Anspruch nehmen die Weisheit mit
Löffeln gefressen zu haben wir machen
uns schuldig wenn wir etwas tun wir
machen aber auch uns schuldig wenn wir
nichts tun und ich finde das gebietet es
mit einem gewissen Maß an Respekt diesen
Streit zu suchen
ich lass mich jedenfalls von sowas nicht
anstecken ich stelle aber auch fest ob
das twitter ist ob das andere Medien
sind es wird inzwischen aufeinander
drauf gehauen ich glaube das
verunsichert eher Menschen und das trägt
nicht dazu bei dass wir in diesen
Kriegszeiten Sicherheit und Vertrauen
ausstrahlen deswegen
abrüsten cool bleiben und wieder über
die Sache reden und auch streiten
einmaligen sie wollten vorhin ja also
mehrere Dinge also die Sachlichkeit bin
ich auch dafür es ist allerdings dann
schon interessant wenn der Chef des
Kanzleramtes von Teenagern und
v2-syndrom spricht das ist ja keine
keine evidenzbasierte Argumentation die
da kommt aus der Bundesregierung aus dem
vertrauten das kannst du wie sie gerade
geschildert haben den großen Plan mag
ich auch noch nicht zu sehen das Ende
der Geschichte haben wir erstens noch
nicht erreicht und zweitens hat der
Kaiser am Chef gesagt doch im Oktober
das ist ein Plan nicht gibt
wie man eigentlich die Ukraine
unterstützen will jetzt kann es sein
dass das nicht gestimmt hat dann ist das
interessante öffentliche Aussage gewesen
es hatte sich aber bislang auch nicht
vermittelt dass es diesen Plan
tatsächlich gegeben hat und wenn wir uns
zurück erinnern an das was die USA
gemacht haben was sozusagen das die
geheimen Diplomatie gewesen ist die
Stadt gefunden hat dann ist seit dem
Sommer der Druck öffentlich halb
öffentlich auf die Bundesregierung durch
die USA massiv angestiegen werden und
uns an die Nachrichten die aus der
amerikanischen Botschaft von der
Botschafterin selber gekommen sind
da war schon Druck im Kessel ja und die
Amerikaner waren zutiefst genervt über
ein Deutschland das auf der einen Seite
sagt genau wir reißen das ganze hier und
auf euch wir können uns auf uns
verlassen und auf der anderen Seite
braucht es das neue Investment der
Amerikaner die so viel schon geschult
hat haben und Europa schafft es nicht
für den für den Krieg der auf seinem
eigenen Kontinent stattfindet das ganze
Ding alleine seit dem Ersten Weltkrieg
haben es nicht hingekriegt er ist
zweiter Welt
nicht wir kriegen die Sicherheit in
Europa alleine nicht geredet
sie dürfen sofort Frau Hermann die
mitwirkowski hat vorhin als
Marianne Strack Zimmermann zu hören war
genickt
an welcher Stelle als sie als sie sagte
das ist ein historisches versagen so
sinngemäß sehen Sie das auch so wie wie
bewerten sie das als jemand das ein
bisschen von außen drauf schaut speziell
auch die Aussage da gibt es jetzt Putin
der klopft sich auf die Schenkel so hat
sie sich ausgedrückt über das was da
gerade in Deutschland diskutiert wird
wie das in Russland betrachtet wird ja
genau also ja welches Bild geben wir da
auch als Deutschland nach außen ab das
ist ja die frage ich glaube dass jetzt
haben wir eine große Auswahl von
Propagandisten auf dem russischen
Fernsehen wegen dieser Panzerlieferungen
und es ist deswegen weil die Lage wird
für Wladimir Putin und für russische
Armee Ukraine relativ verschlimmert und
es ist klar dass das macht die russische
Regierung nervös ne ähm ich betrachte
die ganze ähm panzerlieferungssituation
natürlich genau wie alle Russen jetzt
irgendwie wie eine vorsetzung in diesem
Mythos des Zweiten Weltkrieges
und ist auch so beim russischen
Fernsehen dargestellt ob ein so eine
deutsche Teilnahme in diesem Krieg und
insbesondere die
Waffenlieferungen inklusive bahnzeile
wird als eine Prüfung und
so Fortsetzung nationalsozialistische
Politik von Deutschland gegen Russland
dargestellt wir werden es auch gleich
noch mal hören Propaganda russischen
Fernsehen
genau aber Propaganda wir sowieso jede
Lage für seinen Nutzen ne wenn
[Musik]
Herr Scholz noch in Zweifel war ob er
die Panzer Russland Entschuldigung der
Ukraine liefern sollte die russische
Protagonisten stellten Soda ob er unter
der Produkte Amerikaner war und trotzdem
unabhängig sein bleiben konnte jetzt
aber werden schon wir sicherlich so
sehen ob Deutschland überhaupt keine
unabhängige Außenpolitik habt hat und
sie nun die Puppen von amerikanischen
Amerikaner an ja mann sie wollten gerade
ja genau also
was sehr interessantes gesagt nämlich
dass es äh das deutsche Panzer ein hohes
Symbol sind für den
nationalsozialistischen Angriffskrieg
gegenüber Russland auch das war ja ein
Grund warum Scholz nicht so gerne nur
Leoparden da sehen wollte sondern warum
ist ihm so wichtig war auch andere
Panzer aus anderen Ländern der
Alliierten zu haben damit eben klar ist
das hier ist ein gemeinsamer NATO
Einsatz das ist ist jetzt nicht nur
Deutschland das Leoparden schickt und
dann wollte ich noch mal was zu Herrn
Bölling sagen also ich glaube auch da
sind wir am Rhein Meinung ich glaube
dass die Haltung von Scholz ist
natürlich Deutschland liefert das hat ja
auch rot gesagt dass wir
so viel liefern oder mehr liefern als
alle europäischen Länder und da wirklich
stark einsteigen aber was Scholz nicht
sein will und das sagt er ja immer
wieder und das finde ich total richtig
er will nicht dass Deutschland
Führungsnation ist sondern er möchte
dass wir sozusagen in Gleichklang mit
den anderen mit allen NATO-Partnern in
der Ukraine helfen und er möchte nicht
dass die Deutschen sozusagen allein
vorangehen und das finde ich unheimlich
schlau weil sonst würde ja weil
beispielsweise von den Polen ausgenutzt
wurde die ihren ganzen Wahlkampf damit
bestreiten immer an die deutsche Gefühle
zu äh artikulieren das wäre für
Deutschland verhindern weil dann werden
wir auch immer schuld wenn das schief
geht
das ist ein Teil von Verantwortung dass
man für den Teil den man leisten kann
dann Verantwortung auch übernimmt aber
also wieso können
also wenn sie führen dann gehen sie ja
nicht alleine das sind ja zwei
unterschiedliche Sachen wenn sie führen
dann haben sie eine politische Idee für
Mehrheiten oder aber sogar die
Gesamtheit ihrer Partner suchen dahinter
zu versammeln das was wir jetzt sehen
nee das was wir jetzt sehen ist zum
Jagen getragen werden ja sie hätten die
Möglichkeit gehabt auch mit der mit
nicht mit der Frage also wir auf der
einen Seite die militärische Wirkung der
Panzer in der Ukraine das ist das was
jetzt möglicherweise kommen wird sie
haben auf der anderen Seite teilweise
unabhängig davon die Frage wie wird das
wie wird das Außen und Allianz politisch
fort über diesen über diesen Effekt
hinaus und ich glaube den Teil den kann
man da kann man sagen na ja das sieht
nicht nach Führung aus jetzt können Sie
sagen der ganze hat das nie gesagt hat
die Ministerin gesagt wenn sie in die
Erklärung von 27.02 gehen dann liest
sich das ziemlich so und wir haben auch
schon im Koalitionsvertrag drin stehen
dass wir eigentlich viel mehr auf die
auf die Bedürfnisse Bedürfnisse und auf
die Probleme der zentralen
osteuropäischen Staaten hören wollen
aber wenn es konkret wird dann geht es
nicht so offensichtlich also wohler die
Führung ist oder wo sozusagen
mit Verweis auf die Größe Deutschlands
und was uns deswegen alles sozusagen
zufällt
da machen wir irgendwie keinen keinen
Sinn raus es ist im Grunde genommen eine
Politik die wir die wir im Grunde über
Merkel lange Zeit lang gehabt haben und
die wir jetzt wiedersehen
würden sie jetzt sagen dass das Erfolg
war wenn die airbrems kommen und war das
ein Erfolg wenn England sagte schicken
14 challenget du ähm Kampfpanzer und es
ist ein Erfolg wenn die Franzosen ihre
Spur Panzer schicken also es kommen ja
mehr Panzer an in der Ukraine als wenn
angekommen werden wenn Deutschland immer
nur geführt hätte das ist doch
materieller Erfolg den
Scholz mit seiner Diplomatie tatsächlich
erregt also am Ende haben die Ukraine
100 Panzer mehr als sie sonst gehabt
hätten und ich finde man kann jetzt
diese 100 Panzer einfach wegaddieren das
tut ja auch keiner ach so aber die sind
aber nur da weil du Scholz diese
Diplomatie führt oder verfolgt die er
macht nämlich zu sagen wir bewegen uns
nur wenn alle liefern
also wollen sie mir sagen dass wir
kriegen langsam wieder
zu schicken dass das abgesprochen war
mit Scholz
das stimmt doch nicht das ist doch ein
eine Bewegung gewesen wo der
französische Präsident gesagt hat ich
mache das jetzt einfach mal
das Gefühl nein nein also es hat eine
Absprache gegeben zwischen Frankreich
zwischen Washington und Berlin und der
französische Präsident hat einige
Stunden einen Tag glaube ich vorher
diese Entscheidung öffentlich gemacht
nach einem Telefonat mit dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten und zeitgleich
haben dann der amerikanische Präsident
und der deutsche Bundeskanzler erklärt
dass die Mörder die Schützenpanzer
geliefert werden das war eine
abgestimmte Geschichte das war
sicherlich nicht schön so ähm aber
interessant weil sie gerade sagt das
kommt
in drei Buchstaben vor also vor bevor
diese Entscheidung sozusagen getroffen
worden ist in diese gemeinsame
Entscheidung quasi hat er schon
öffentlich gemacht Hammer hat es getan
das fand ich super optimal diplomatisch
zu sagen
im Gegensatz zum Jagen tragen Druck
aufbauen von allen Seiten Dampf machen
dafür sorgen dass sich da jemand in
Deutschland bewegt ich will mal daran
erinnern dass es auch in den USA sorgen
gegeben hat die immer wieder artikuliert
werden beispielsweise bei der Batterie
oder bei der Abwehr dass man gesagt hat
wir wollen nur eine bestimmte Reichweite
haben damit russische Staatsterritorium
nicht betroffen werden kann also es hat
auch dort immer wieder klare Ansagen
gegeben weil auch für die USA wichtig
warten die NATO darf nicht Kriegspartei
werden und das sind wir auch nicht
geworden also sind wir nicht die
Einzigen die manchmal etwas auf der
Bremse standen um zu gewährleisten dass
wir das und Konzert mit anderen machen
das würde ich so wirklich ganz anders
sehen also ersten
Ozean dazwischen ja erstmal zwischen uns
oder Amerika das ist ein Krieg der
findet vor unserer eigenen Haustür statt
und ich frage mich schon von außen
betrachtet
für wen oder wofür spricht diese
Regierung eigentlich würde ich immer
sagen kommt drauf an wenn man fragt wenn
man die Außenministerin fragt dann sagt
sie also wir würden uns einer Zustimmung
für die Lieferung von Leoparden seitens
der Polen oder so würden wir uns nicht
in den Weg stellen Robert Habeck sagt
das gleiche Rolf Mütze nicht sagten auf
gar keinen Fall das wollen wir
eigentlich nicht Lars Klingbeil ihr
Parteichef sagt für viele Staaten auf
der Welt sind wir ein wichtiger Partner
und genau deshalb erwarten sie dass
Deutschland auf internationaler Ebene
mehr Initiative zeigt und eine
Führungsrolle einnimmt heute
Strategiepapier also wie passt das alles
zusammen wie passt dazu ein Kanzler der
im Wahlkampf immer wieder mit dem
berühmten Satz konfrontiert worden ist
und ihm bestätigt hat auch hier in
dieser Sendung wer bei mir Führung
bestellt der bekommt sie an welcher
Stelle ist das wirklich Führung wenn man
immer so wie Herr Möhlin sagt wirklich
zum Jagen getragen wird aber er lernt
sie wollen doch Führungsverantwortung
Deutschlands nicht alleine auf die Frage
reduzieren wann wir ankündigen ein
bestimmte Waffensysteme zu liefern dass
der Bundeskanzler drei Tage nach
Ausbruch dieses grauenhaften Krieges
eine Rede im Bundestag gehalten hat mit
der Zeitenwende wo er ein 100 Milliarden
Euro Paket für die Bundeswehr zugesagt
hat da ist einigen meiner Kolleginnen
und Kollegen im Bundestag erst einmal
der Mond offen geblieben die haben damit
nicht gerechnet wenn man daran erinnern
dass es sicherlich auch Olaf Scholz
geschafft hat im Rahmen der G20 den
Chinesen abzuhängen das durch sein Büro
auch durch seinen auch durch seinen
dortigen Besuch das China eine klare
Ansage gemacht hat eine Atom Eskalation
und auch die Bedrohung mit Atomwaffen
durch Russland ist völlig inakzeptabel
und sie wissen selber welchen Einfluss
auch China nach wie vor auf Russland hat
das sind finde ich diplomatische Erfolge
das ist ein großer diplomatischer Volker
auch mit berücksichtigen und wie gesagt
bei der waffenfrage
ich glaube ich ist Teamspiel auch
wichtig die einen sind etwas forscher
etwas temperamentvoller rot er ist etwas
zurückhaltender aber am Ende stimmen die
Ergebnisse herunter ganz kurz also
nochmal ja Kommunikation wenn man die
ganze Zeit sagt keine allein Gänge das
Argument mit den alleinggängen
zerbröselt ihnen seit Wochen die
Amerikaner Herr willi hat darauf
hingewiesen haben schon im Sommer gesagt
pass auf wenn ihr das machen wollt dann
macht das Klammer auf wir hätten
eigentlich gerne dass sie das macht ich
höre jetzt von großem Ärger großen Krach
denn es ihm im Hintergrund gegeben hat
weil die Amerikaner die Geduld verloren
haben mit dieser zögerlichen Haltung das
heißt dieses Argumente alleinige ist
plötzlich weg die Polen sagen wir würden
liefern die Spanier deuten an wir würden
es möglicherweise auch die Franzosen
gehen nach vorne die Engländer gehen
nach vorne und wir sagen ja aber allein
gehen wollen wir nicht und setzen dann
die Amerikaner unter Druck und sagen
denen das machen wir aber nur wenn ihr
euch euren euren Kampfpanzer wenn ihr
denkt ich bin jetzt zum mindestens
ziemlich sicher ob es dieses dieses
jungte wie man dieser Tage so häufig
liest gab es diese diese conditiusine
quanol diese Bedingung die sagt wenn ihr
nicht dann machen wir auch nicht gab es
das also ich will jetzt hier nicht
spekulieren aber wissen sie das nicht
also es gab keinen jungtim das ist ja
auch deutlich gemacht worden aber es gab
sicherlich einen großen es gibt einen
großen Wunsch das Kanzlers und auch
anderer das in allen Bereichen die USA
eine zentrale Rolle spielen und wir
müssen aber ganz ehrlich sagen sogar bei
Herrn Mölling ohne die USA hätte die
Ukraine schon längst verloren ohne die
USA stünden wir blank das könnten auch
anders formulieren und Europäer
insgesamt anders formulieren
Sie sich auf uns hätte verlassen müssen
werden sie schon längste stimmt das ja
dass wir uns alleine stimmt das das
meine wir haben als Europäerinnen und
Europäer hätten wir nicht genügend
erreichen können wir brauchen die USA
und daraus folgt ja auch dass wir uns
sicherheitspolitisch anders aufstellen
aber ich bin erstmal den USA sehr
dankbar hätte ich auch ein anderer
Präsident sein können der sagt kümmert
euch mal bitte alleine darum also ich
bin erst einmal beiden sehr dankbar
dafür dass er diese Solidarität mit
Europa aufbringt und dass er uns dabei
hilft dass wir wieder zu friedlichen und
stabilen und sicheren Verhältnissen in
Europa kommen danke Präsident beiden